les indestructibles ils ont insisté et
on a insisté pour qu'il soit avec nous
ce soir à peu disparu
oh
ils sont là les champions d'europe merci
des chiens
quel bonheur merci d'être là les gars
bon alors et qui alla alors je vois
qu'elle est alors bonjour et équipé
l'équipe et l'équipe est équipé daniel
alors c'est grave at war c'est touchant
dans les vestiaires j'essaie de mettre
un peu long mais on sera content moi
bien je tente encore une fashion que
justement ce nom on va regarder vous que
regarder ce qu'ils font dans les
vestiaires on est heureux de les avoir
puisque ce sont les plus grands
champions zilina il est juste un
marchepied
l'afutt monde sur la table
assure voulait déjà dire la coke et
adorait ça bouge cette mère a fait gaffe
féminine gaf a la mienne voilà ah là là
on fait moins les malins reviens-moi
ouvrir sa gueule sur nos plateaux
c'est vrai que je le dis les plus grands
champions de tous les temps qu'est ce
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'être
peut-être aussi énormes au reste
sinon rendez pas compte j'étais avec
vous dans les landes dans la loge il
parler tranquillement champion olympique
champion d'europe champion du monde y'a
quoi maintenant y'a quoi daniel champion
de touche pas à mon poste on à la
médaille et je te la rachète tout de
suite on ne tue mais que veux-tu mon âge
mais allez tu sais quoi à 25 euros je
parle direct avec la bellagio regardez
ce qu'ils faisaient dans les vestiaires
regarder les japonais patients
panpan porte
alors les gérer on a une surprise pour
vous parce qu'on vous a fait une chanson
spécialement pour l'équipe de france de
handball vous aimez les cartouches
eh bien il est là avec tout ce soir
sébastien pas te laisser les filles il
passe alors j'étais sur la béquille
le but est de ceux-là je veux juin mais
c'était la classe de la touche lors de
mon slip à aulas n'a fait tellement bien
jusqu'au bout des doigts alors vous avez
fait c'est vrai prénom mais vous êtes un
petit peu d'amour avec la coupe là je
suis d origine je devrais je suis la
côte d'opale ont alors j'ai été une
société les handballeurs j'attends des
champions l'équipe et c'est pour vous
j'ai vous également et sautez berio un
peu d'émotion alors certes ce tir excusé
le allez allez allez musique qui faisait
partie
rappelez vous c'est pour vous
c'est une bande de mecs à la carrure de
déménageur
non c'est pas des couilles molles cd en
valeur quand il se pointe à l'entrée du
vestiaire
l'équipe d'en face revel crédit dans les
sanitaires situent les ai pas
si jamais tu les siffler et envoie aux
urgences juste avec une biffle on aurait
dit que les danois jouaient tous en
babouches tellement les indestructibles
leur en but qu'a toujours lui va
doucement en pompant il rendit une
cartouche pop en e-learning cartouche ni
cartouches sont pas les seuls mais ils
ont une cartouche qui vaut quand même le
sport c'est mignon mais non
avec une d'honneur joseph jeté un sac de
couchage
j'suis sûr cor trompette il faut un trou
dans le carrelage tous leurs adversaires
ton côté rouge et rose chez leur mère
merci de rombies une cartouche au mans
ils leur ont remis une carte ou jamais
or il règne une cartouche année leur
mettrais bien une cartouche
ils sont pas chasseur mais si l'euro
campan
cette éclosion
merci les gars mais du fond du coeur
merci
magnifique
yakhi si vous pouvez faire ça un faux
dit tout de suite ayhan la cuisine qui
peuvent faire ça c'est pareil c'est pas
ça pas d'âge les gars on va faire un
petit jeu c'est un micro ça on va faire
un petit jeu thierry omeyer il est là
thierry tu vas dire avec moi j'essaie de
te mettre un tir trois possibilités se
consacrer une coque si l'on met pas
j'irai aux cages et vous ferez ce que
vous voudrez vous ferez plaisir ses
parents